hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 2019 FIBA World Cup it's a game
three empty motor Java versus England
and in the previous rounding one a very
nice game with the white pieces a
brilliant see if you will and this is a
job was the best chance to get back into
the match he now has the white pieces
and well if he doesn't use his chance
now tomorrow he gets black again and
it's very unlikely that you will be able
to get back into the match so it will be
very interesting to see what he prepared
for teeing as in Game one he prepared
the a very nice idea against the
Marshall attack but it's very soon
unwise unwind it into a draw so without
further ado let's check out the game
with the white pieces that a job of
opens with E for with e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 same as in the
as in Game one with a six more fees
defense to the reuleaux PES of the up to
a four and the knife to f6 so far
repeating game one with castles better
job of Bishop to e7 rook to e1 so
everything the same setting up for for
the Marshall b5 Bishop to b3 and ding
castles and here c3 again our job of
invite sitting to go for the Marshall
attack and being does as he didn't
really have any problems in Game one and
since he's a leading by point point in
the match he doesn't mind the drawing
this game as well with ecat force on d5
Knight captures on d5 Knight captures
Knight captures and now rook captures on
e5 so everything the same is in Game one
c6 defending the knight and now d3 with
Bishop to b6 rook to e1 and now Bishop
to f5 so still everything the same as in
Game one Queen to f3 going after the
bishop on f5 Queen to h4 now threatening
Queen captures on h2 of course we
already explained in Game one why this
doesn't work
g3 attacking the Queen Queen to h3 and
now in Game one we had Knight 2 d2 and
we said that I think already had this
position on the board that he played it
against Kerrigan where Bishop to e3 was
played and here
Raja Bo goes for this idea Bishop to e3
so here we have a deviation from game 1
and ok he offers the DS
born with Bishop captures and III and
now Knights to d2 gaining rapid
development with Queen to f5 now
offering a queen trade and now the shop
to d4 buy a job of just putting the
bishop to a much nicer diagonal opening
up at the e-file for the rook we look at
the d8 by ding and the now comes a four
so this has all been played before
nothing new with h6 biting and now comes
h4 and rook a to c8 so although all the
pieces are pretty much developed and
here there is a one game the one we were
mentioning Carter can already played
against England in the single Cup and
the ding had this position against
Wesley so as well in the candidates 2018
or both games were drawn in both games
continued with a capture Sun b5 but here
we have a new move by the job of he
prepared Queen captures Queen on f5 so
it is as a move 21 that we have a
completely new game so what is this
poison that Java brought to this game
with Queen captures on f5 that will
shoot complicate matters for ding as he
really needs a win in this game
well of course being recaptured with
Bishop captures and now comes the Knight
to e4 and ding here really started
spending time on the clock for his next
move he has to decide what to do does
how does he defend the bishop for
example does he go to e7 does he go to
FA does he go to b8 maybe does does he
not defend the c.push c5 all of these
ideas are seemingly nice but you know
you really have to make sure if you
don't know the position so here dink
took some half an hour I think it was 29
minutes but still a lot of time and in
the end he played Bishop to f8 just to
show if for example Bishop the EA to
white gets a very nice game with a 5 and
then you will have the c5 outpost for
your knight are gonna go for the a6 pawn
and black will have a very hard time
defending it so black will most likely
have to give up the bishop there and
here white just continues the game with
with the bishop pair in a in a slightly
better position on the other hand c5 was
also a possibility I think after the
game it was mentioned that c5 is is a
known drawing line by a job of but you
know it's it's hard to find such an idea
over the board
you would you would go for some ignite
characters on d6 rook captures on d6 and
now Bishop to e5 attacking the rook rook
goes back and now with c-4 white would
get the further complicate matters but
all in all black should be able to to
survive everything but okay dink went
rushing back to a fate and now comes
Knight the c5 and here after this night
to c5
your job is going after the a6 pawn and
it's not not all that clear what to do
here so here adding had a nice sip of
his water if you don't believe it I even
have a photo of this there you have it
ding having a nice sip and he decided to
defended with a nice tactic he defends
it with Knight the be for this is not
possible the a6 bone is defended and if
you capture the night here you get a
roof capped or sandy for you you lose
the bishop on d4 and now after knife
captures on a6 you get a rook to a 8
capture some b5 capture some v5 and now
you get this position where you even
though white is up upon not doesn't
really do you all that much the knight
is pretty much stuck there if you move
it then of course black will be able to
recapture the b4 point without a problem
probably pick up the beat upon as well
at some point so after night the before
we have looked a 5 by a job of again
improving the position of his pieces and
attacking the bishop on f5 so now ding
has to decide that it does he go back
Bishop the g6 does he go back up to h7
does he defend the bishop with the g6
it's hard to decide all all moves have
their merits but for example if you play
someone like Bishop d7 you immediately
get a capture sandy 5 captures and
looked at a 7 you know really with a
very active game from white so instead
ding decides to keep the bishop on a
five he plays g6 and okay we have a
capture some b5 and now Dean doesn't
play a captures and allows rook to a7
but instead goes C captures and b5
offering sorry offering the a6 pawn but
a job of played an even trickier move
instead not Knight captures on a6 but
instead Knight the e6 and here again
being started the calculating here in
this time
took a really big sip of his water we
also have a nice photo of that there we
have it thing with the the nice sip of
water and well what's the idea behind 96
obviously the question is can you
capture it if you play F captures and e6
then white what has and what has a very
clean advantage after a certain move but
feel free to pause the video while I
give you a couple of seconds and find
what Rachel's idea is in this position
if you were able to do it
congratulations as it's it's a really
difficult line to spot and for those if
you just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures on f5 the the pony spin
here you cannot capture but this point
so you have to play G captures on f5 and
I'll get Bishop captures any sex with
check checking the king you're gonna
pick up the rope King h7 and now you
pick it up and now you have to decide do
you capture on c8 and allow C characters
and b4 or do you go nice the c2 which is
terrible
even though it comes with with an
in-between move and attack on the rook
on a1 now you get Bishop character son f
f5 check just picking up that night so
after the King moves for example here
you would be for example up a whole
piece so a lot of complications here
after night to e6 but the Dean
calculates well and of course he
captures it with the bishop now we have
rook captures on e6 better job of F
captures and e6 and Bishop captures on
e6
with Chuck and now came to h7 so now
it's a bit different as the knight will
be able to use that you know it's
efficient to with a nice to see - as you
will not have DF v square to pick up the
night since the g6 bone is still there
but with Bishop captures on c8 rook
captures on c8
ding took almost 20 minutes to decide
whether he wants to go rook after since
yet or to go for this in-between move
Knight to the c2 night the c2 is
definitely a possibility as now we
already mentioned that the g6 pawn
blocks Bishop to a5
for example rook see one Knight captures
a bishop but now after pawn recaptures
the bishop and unsee it is protected so
here or the game continues white is up
upon and it's well if ro captures then
you start picking up the Queen side
pawns it doesn't doesn't look nice but
it was opposed
ability instead ding went for rook
captures and c8 and now we have C
character son before so Dean prefers
this to that as here White has a double
beep on and he immediately goes for them
with rook to c4 and this is the first
time our job of started spending time on
his clock as he didn't he didn't
calculate this rook after since the 8th
line at all he who was a canoe he was a
mostly prepared for knife to sea to the
line that we just shown so here he spent
some 15 minutes and his next move and he
has to decide if you go bishop the c3
doesn't really do anything black will
just capture it for example if rook
captures an a6 you're gonna get Bishop
captures and c3 captures captures and
now of course you play rook the b6 ago
after after the past pawn Ruby 3
defending and it's it's a clean draw on
the other hand if you go something like
Bishop to e5 then Bishop to g7 is is
pretty much a clean draw because now
after the bishop moves yes you're gonna
defend your before before pawn rook c6
attacks the bishop and the defense d a6
pawn so here Rajah bow found a better
move Dan bishop the c3 Bishop e5 he
played Bishop to f6 which is now
different now if you try the same idea
of a pusher of the g7 for example which
was played in the game you will get you
will get Bishop to e7 and now there is
no Roxy says there is Roxy sucks ding
did play it but now it doesn't come with
an attack on the bishop here as the
Bishop from f6 came to East 7 instead
here so it will not be a target for the
rook so it is an improvement we have
looked a to better job of seems like an
odd place to put a rock very passive but
his plan is he wants to play b3 the b2
point is a target on b2 anyway so he
just wants to put it on white square and
after this he can start bringing his
rook into the game we have King to g8
ding starts in improving the position of
his King and then now Bishop back to c5
just posing the C file for dings rook
King to f7 and now King to g2 and here
King to ecigs abiding there was also the
option of playing Bishop to f8 it seems
like a reasonable idea it's a very
strong leadership cutting a rook
entering the game but the problem is why
- just continuous king of three and
after you even if you trade it captures
captures you're not really gonna capture
here I mean if you don't be for his
coming white will cement his advantage
there and if you capture it then you get
two rogue chapters on a six and if rook
to c2 then Whitehead h5 now which pretty
much cleans up the King side the G
captures rook captures and h6 look after
son b2 and the now rook captures on h5
it's two to one in a rock endgame but
those are two connected past points so
white would white would definitely have
the the edge here so after rook to King
to g2 being further improves the
position of a skin King e6 he wants to
get f5 maybe maybe even a four if
possible and now b3 the b2 pawn is no
longer a target and the reserve is ready
to bring his rook into the game also the
situation on the clock this is move 36
formal moves until time control it's 58
minutes for a job of and only 16 minutes
for ding with h5 by dink and now King to
f3 kink the f5 not allowing the reserves
King to further go into the position and
now comes look to d2 and now it seems
like dink has some very active contra
plate with a 5 but it's only an illusion
for example if you go a 5 yes you cannot
capture because rook captures on c5 but
Rishabha would have looked at d5 check
here and now if King he sits just Ruby
g5 and it's gonna be very hard to
prevent rook captures on g6 you could
lose the rook and c6 if you move the
King for example King d7 just be
captures on f5 now that the rookies on
the 5th rank the bishop is protected
you're just gonna play b4 and and have a
protected class pawn it's gonna be game
over for ding
so instead Dean finds the best of the
ephod it is the strongest move in the
position and it prevents the roof from
reaching the g5 square of course our job
of plays a truck to d5 he further
improves his position and he now forces
thing to make any move but not any move
it doesn't really work for ding you
can't really play nothing if you if you
move for example something weird like
Bishop th are gonna get Bishop to d4
just attacking the pin
so dink has to move the king and here
ding plays kinked ESX which is not the
most precise move as it allows King to
e4 right away a more resilient idea from
ding would have been instead of King to
e6 King to f6
it just says okay if we come to e4 I'm
just gonna play rook to e6 and force
your King back for example if you play
King back to f3 I'm just gonna repeat
rook back to c6 and you have to come up
with something else so this was a
definitely a more resilient idea than a
straight up King to e6 but okay I think
is a low on the clock and this is move
39 he has to make one move until time
control with kinky for better job of and
now dingos as the bishop is under attack
he goes Bishop to f6 so now this is move
40 the time control has been reached and
the players have received an additional
half an hour on their clocks so what do
you play here f4 of course at hijabs
idea is f5 he wants the trade EF pawn
for the Jeep on and then
wreak capture the h5 point with the rook
and ding has to make a move here ding
plays Bishop the c3 it's a waiting move
just to see what a jobber will play and
as I already mentioned what the reserves
idea was a bishop two seater we didn't
really do anything to prevent this
so f5 with check and now if you capture
it just roll captures next move reg over
will recapture the h5 pawn is gonna be
up to two connected passports on the
Kings side it will be game over for ding
so dink cannot allowed to trade here we
have King to f7 and now comes rook the
d7 check
much better than just capturing here if
we captured and ding will recapture and
now if of course you can capture on h5
butting in capture on g3
so not something you want to do so
instead f5 check dingos back King to f7
and now rook d7 check so what do you do
here ding plays King to g8 King to e8
also possible but dingos King to g8 and
he loves a very nice move from a job of
it is it is really a beautiful winning
move so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the move that a job of
played in this position while I play
give you a couple of seconds so for
who were able to do it you are a
brilliant endgame player and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to d6 cut off the rubes
defense to the pawn here and for sting
to capture and allow your King to go
after the h5 point and now dings rook
really isn't doing all that much doesn't
really have a good square so didn't
captured an f5 with King captures on f5
and now being played Bishop to g7 he
tried one last trick for example if our
job will attack the D H point with King
to g6 then of course Dean would have
bishop the faith just going after the
the piece here so he would win a piece
most likely win the game then but a job
of course is not interested in such
trickery he plays King to g5 and it was
in this position unmoved 46 that Dingley
resigned the game and incredible as it
is but raja baath manages to get back
into the match not I'm not saying
incredible as it is because I think is
such a huge favor but it's just that
dink is leading the match and he only
needs the draw and to win an undermanned
against Dingley rand who really doesn't
lose games in classical time format
almost almost at all it's really just a
really impressive feat and the rajabu
mentioned in an interview after the game
that he actually had something similar
prepared for being in round 1 but he
didn't decided not to play it so that's
why he decided to go for that quick draw
against the marshal attack but here he
really out plays ding and it's it's a
very hard to pinpoint where where ding
went wrong there were a lot of
situations where Dean could have
improved his game but those were like
very very little improvements that that
basically only the engine sees and this
is what it takes the beat being in a
classical game so a job of Kim and
extremely prepared you know at one point
I believe for a job of had like a 1 hour
lead on the clock or maybe 4 to 5
minutes I wasn't really checking but it
was a huge leader Jabba made all of his
moves pretty much instantly it was only
at that point that that I mentioned that
the Rajah who actually started spending
time yeah definitely a brilliant game
better job of taking accounting Liron in
a classical game
really impressive tomorrow is Game four
of the classical time format think again
with the white pieces will he be able to
finish off this match in the classical
section or will we go to Rapids boots
and maybe even Armageddon definitely
going to be interesting so hope you're
ready for that but yeah that's pretty
much the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Pablo Mohan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - all my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
soon
continuing this well coverage of the
amazing World Cup that worth enjoying
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and and so on so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day